this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you [__]
Savages it's Monday the 14th of November
the joint is brought to you by my
favorite I'm letting you know about this
because they're going to have a
tremendous Black Friday sale over and on
it I want you to start getting ready so
2023 will be a way better year shroom
Tech new mood Alpha Brain the new Alpha
Brain plus they got so many new things
over and on it I can't even keep up they
got some online classes online uh
kettlebell classes go to honda.com right
now read go to the website see what they
got to offer listen I can't help you
with kettlebells or Club bells or
anything like that but I can help you
with nutrition so Alpha Brain shroom
Tech
protein powders that's where Joey comes
in putting cold joint Joey or church and
get 10 off your first offer it on it you
first order it on it all right let's get
this party started it's Monday we got
[__] to talk about [__] lickers
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
joint
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday the 14th of October of
November we're [__] halfway there we
got six weeks left in 2022 it was a
great weekend great week last week we're
looking forward to another [__] great
week
just uh
great weekend for me I went to the
movies and I got to tell you something
about three months ago we had a talk on
on the joint about [__] movies you
know what they meant to me as a child
and how much I enjoyed Cinema and
I got to tell you I've gone to the
movies I think that they have taken
the [__] excitement away from people
doing anything that's what's happened
I've noticed this and they take away
little things at a time like guys we all
grew up we had this [__] chit chat
about the movies and how much we loved
the movies and it's great you would go
to the movies on a Saturday and stay for
two movies and you thought like you were
getting over and [__] but remember all
that [__] you going to the movie
theaters and staying and catching an
extra movie guess what [__] now
they're getting us back for all the
[__] times we sat there on a [__]
satellite and watched two movies that we
weren't supposed to watch let me tell
you something man
in my eyes for me
I've been to movie theaters from [__]
Toronto all the way to Miami to
California
I think it's over it's [__] over
because you know the other day I'm
trying to be a nice guy I mean that a
wakanda uh Black Panther double feature
on Thursday and I was like six hours in
a [__] movie theater is a bit severe
for me and my daughter and my wife I
said let's just catch Friday let's catch
Friday early we'll go to Red Robin we'll
get the [__] endless steak fries you
killed two birds with one [__] Stone
I always got a plan when it comes to the
movie theater a couple Edibles boom okay
so you get to the [__] movie theater
it's great you know it's all new modern
you scan your phone my wife is part of
the AMC Club whatever they give extended
benefits and you get a discount on
popcorn and whatever okay you walk up
again guys ask any of my friends I hate
I'm not [__] cheap
I'm not cheap at all but I'll tell you
what
when I'm standing to the side and I hear
my wife and my daughter get a popcorn
and I get a small popcorn and she gets
two drinks no meat there was no hot dogs
there was no nachos I wouldn't eat any
of that [__] the [__] churros I'm not
touching any of that [__] it's bad
enough I gotta eat that [__]
processed popcorn with that [__]
covered butter and that [__] because
that butter ain't really butter you
can't listen you give me you ever get a
piece of butter you wash your hands
you're good that movie buddy you [__]
it's like having yeast infection juice
on your fingers you could watch it 20
[__] times and that little slime will
still be in between your fingers and
[__] I just got rid of the butter slime
at the movie theater but no jokes aside
I'm just hanging there and also I hear
the lady say 66 [__] dollars
we got three Cokes and three [__]
popcorns and I can't oh water
don't I'm exaggerating it was sixty
dollars sixty dollars and like 66 cents
I didn't say a [__] word
but on the walk to the movie theater I'm
like
sixty dollars
for three I looked at my popcorn because
I never even look
so you need to tell me in today's world
a regular [__] popcorn is nine
dollars
to nine [__] dollars for a regular
popcorn
how does the family of four [__] even
afford that
no wonder they sneak their [__] own
food in I would sneak it into if I know
it was 9 27 for a little bag now listen
I don't need no more than that but the
next size over was like [__] 16 and
they have like a special for it like get
a a huge tub of [__] processed
[__] popcorn and get a a large
[__] drink for like twenty four
dollars or something like that I'm like
okay it's money it's not even real who
gives a [__] let's go enjoy the movie
okay
theater seven I go in
guys
there was a half hour a [__] trailers
not 15 minutes remember in the old days
like they gave you one Trail after the
other one Trail after the other this the
theater would go dark
then they would start another Trail
after like three minutes then the
theater would go dark then they start
another trailer every five it was
[__] absurd and every trailer you
could live without watching any of those
[__] movies from Avatar I listen who
gives a [__] what's coming on April
2023. let's focus on the next Christmas
movies how many you got you got none
wakanda was the last [__] move you
put together a couple stupid movies
together but you're not gonna [__]
make up the year in the movie theater
unless we go to box office that's who
you take the [__] sixty dollars for
popcorn from that's not enough
half hour
I could see my she's a [__] kid I can
see her feet going dad what the [__] is
going on in here I could see me being an
[__] but a [__] child is like what
the [__] and then
after it's all said and done after the
be quiet and don't text and [__] they
hit you with a [__] Nicole Kidman
video
of her walking into the movie theater
ordering a drink to show you how easy it
is like there's never there's never no
lines when Nicole Kidman goes to [__]
theater she just walked through sat down
you know she's looking at the screen
that's another five [__] minutes and
then she goes enjoy the show really how
can I enjoy it when I just sat here for
a [__] half hour just staring into
[__] the Oblivion now the movie
starts and listen it was a good movie
for what it was my daughter thinks the
the first one is better than the second
one and I agree it's just entertainment
whatever the [__] but
I sat down and I didn't complain I
didn't make a Yelp review I don't do any
of that [__] okay
I'm sitting there going how is
the theater business whatever you want
to call it the movie business
how
if I was in trouble with my business
I try to have a meeting with the
stockholders and go how can we make the
experience better for these [__]
people well for starters let's cut the
trailers down to [__] nine minutes
nine minutes that's all I
that's like five movies a minute and a
half a piece give me your message and
[__] shut up and don't don't answer
texts and turn off your phone and let's
get the movie started you have great
chairs that the movie theaters are
comfortable they're clean I'm with you
but that is the most horrible
[__] experience of all time my
neighbor flew to Florida last weekend I
saw him at the [__] gym we were chit
chatting he goes Joey I'm 60 something
years old
I've been flying all my life we have a
home in Nebraska you know because there
were college or going to college in
Nebraska whatever he goes we just bought
a home there because you know we go back
to watch the games and [__] my daughter
because I got to tell you I'm buying an
RV I'm not flying ever again
and he told me about his experience to
Florida how the Newark Airport the lines
The Waiting you just listen if you don't
have TSA whatever or clear you don't
make your planes out of [__] Newark
you just don't make them it's
they have taken like guys
flying used to be so much [__] fun
flying used to be like you couldn't wait
to get on a [__] plane
because you knew it was gonna be a
[__] party who wasn't going to be
drinking in the back who wasn't going to
be getting his dick sucked who's not
sneaking a [__] cigarette you know
who's in the aisles drinking I go over
Mike don't I know you from Philly yeah
what's up man give him a [__] drink
flying has become like [__] from from
being at the airport
to getting on the plane to sitting to
[__] deboarding to the [__] lady
with the dog the guy with the big feet
you know that takes his feet out it has
become a [__] no matter what you pay
for it like you you could pay for a
first class ticket and you're still
gonna have a [__] heart you know
we're paying for a first-class ticket
well you're still going to be late
because the whole plane is [__]
delayed what are you gonna do they're
gonna give you a parachute they're gonna
give you a special [__] treatment you
know it and that's what I say to people
listen I understand you want to go on
vacations and people want to do things
but I don't want to get treated badly
not when I gotta work from my money not
when I gotta do [__] and I gotta tweet
and do a thousand things do I want to
get treated
why would I want to go to the airport to
be get a run around and then to be told
my flight is canceled then when they do
have a flight you [__] lose my
luggage what the experience is horrific
and I'm not trying like I'm not trying
to be negative I'm just speaking about a
fact that affects a bunch of people that
people starting to go you wait guys if
you're thinking of traveling this
holiday
listen guys unless it's a [__] hour
flight or something like that
you're going to get the money that
they're gonna charge you and the
cancellations and all the [__] they're
gonna have this year and covert's gonna
come back you know at least in December
for two weeks and it's not going to be
anything it's just gonna be a [__]
head cold by now it's like a little tear
comes out of your [__] eyes but
they're gonna make the big deal out of
it put the mask back on you know and
it's like they've taken away the I went
to Yankee Stadium this year
dog that's the pride of [__] New York
pride of [__] New York Yankee Stadium
I'll tell you what I'll be honest with
you I can't go back again
that was a [__]
it was you know a mediocre experience I
went to Philly and my experience was
great I'm gonna try silly field next
year you know I hope my they say the
experience is great but all like our
little experiences in life that we used
to [__] enjoy
they beat the [__] out of you they beat
the [__] the [__] out of here
somebody told me they went to eat the
other day and the bill came and they
almost hit them bats you know there's a
family of [__] three working and
they're like what the [__] is going on
with prices guys it's it's unbearable
out there it really [__] is but you
got to live I mean you just can't stay
in your house need TV [__] Dennis
that's not gonna work either
but it's it's crazy how
every time you want to fight you know
yesterday uh Jim florentine's
nephew kept calling me like for the UFC
thing and he kept saying Joey can you
get tickets can you find tickets tickets
were like 350 on Friday and they went up
like 470 on game day and they were like
nosebleeds
and he's like I really want to go blah
blah blah I'm like you know
you're just gonna have to watch out of
the [__] ball like everybody else
470 a ticket you've taken it now on top
of that I got to go to the city
walk around you're already risking
getting [__] hit in the head with a
stick going into the city
so I'm paying 400 yeah you know I got
listen I consider going Joe called uh
Theo was gone my other body was going
with him the guy from Connecticut that
hangs out with Joe
and uh
the problem with me was I had a softball
tournament on Sunday morning at eight
o'clock in the morning with my family so
I know I was I couldn't get home at
[__] two in the morning and get up at
six when I just said [__] it I'll watch
the fight at home for a couple fights I
didn't even know that [__] the guy
one at the end I went to sleep last
night I'm an old man I couldn't take it
no more I'm like I'm good I just wanted
to see Dustin poorey against Michael
Chandler anyway
the chewing fight was kind of [__]
boring and I watched the first fight of
uh Alex perea even though I did take
Alex Pereira for a [__] knockout uh
25 bucks paid 105 so when I woke up this
morning I saw I got lucky last night I
was like damn I should have stayed up
but that's what happens it was a weird
week in comedy last week uh
Cassie dang died
and we did the podcast Wednesday last
week and I was like man Cassie dang that
I thought I was seeing [__] on the
computer you know sometimes I don't look
at it
and then uh somebody asked me did you
hear Cassie thing died for you people
don't know Cassie dang was an
extraordinary
young woman uh I met her at the comedy
store
always
um
she wasn't a regular at the store but
she didn't have to be oh I don't know if
she was I shouldn't say that
uh very funny girl she was a doctor in
real life [__] doctor
[__] doctor and got bit by the comedy
bug and uh I still remember the night
that I slipped and told my hamstring
Annie Lederman a bunch of the girls were
very helpful
but Cassie was fantastic you know she
was
she came right over she goes I don't
have a pain pill for you but let me rub
your thigh a little bit and you know she
was very [__] sweet and I don't know
what happened
um
you know I I haven't inquired I'm going
to call Red Band today and find out what
happened to Cassie because he knows more
from that thing but she was a great lady
and then a guy died last week or he died
yesterday or Saturday
I've just been seeing the things and I
called one of my friends who would know
and he didn't pick up but Bud Friedman
died for you [__] who don't
know what bud Friedman is
he's the left hand to Mitchy Shaw
but she sure did a lot of great things
for stand-up comedy but Bud Freeman did
a lot of [__] great things for
stand-up comedy in his own little way
you know the improvs were all buds
levity lives uh was an offspring of the
of the Improv clubs you know I don't
talk much about the improvs because I'm
a comedy store guy but I gotta tell you
something my bread and butter for all
those years were the Improv The Comedy
Store is where I learned to become a
[__] assassin
The Improv uh was on Melrose to have a
lot of improvs if you watch this podcast
they probably have an improv in your
[__] town anywhere across the United
States West Palm Miami Doral
you know uh Tampa
[__] uh they got them everywhere West
Nyack
[__] [__] what else
L.A
Ontario Breyer Improv
[__] the Oxnard improv it goes on and
on Tempe Improv Houston improv Dallas
improv Green Bay improv Milwaukee improv
they're all over the place and you know
but anyway bud Friedman was uh I still
remember being a kid and watching
evening at The Improv not being a kid
being a young man
and watching mdmt improv and he would
always come out at the end with his
little [__] barnacle and stuff and
talk to the comics and talk to the
audience and uh
when I got to La he was one of those
surreal people you know when you get to
L.A like people tell you yeah bud goes
down there once in a while or Mitzi goes
down once in a while
but I remember being at the Improv the
first time I was there bud Freeman was
there and uh
I got hidden into the [__] improv
through Latino Night okay sometimes when
you get to a club guys
talking to Comics here when you get to a
club you got to figure out a way to get
in there and they'll say wow you know
we'll put you on a list we'll look at
your tape but every once in a while
they'll do a specialty show Arab night
Latin night Puerto Rican night afro
night whatever the [__] it is and
sometimes it's better you know it's not
the way you wanted to get in but it's
the way you get in
I was at the Improv doing a span a cute
Latin night one night
the [__] guy made me put a suit on
and [__]
and uh I I [__] hated it
it was like my first week in LA and they
made me put a [__] suit on
like the first the second night it was
every Sunday
and like the second night
the Second Sunday I was there because I
became a regular at the store a month
not even a month after I got to LA but I
was I had spots at The Improv like if I
got this to LA on a Tuesday I had a spot
that Sunday at The Improv it was [__]
surreal
but the second Sunday I was there when I
was on stage I had never noticed it but
I looked to my left and I saw a little
window
just a little window on the wall and I'm
like what the [__] does that window I go
maybe the the sound guy sits up there
whatever I saw the sound guy in the
bottom with the earphones I wonder what
the [__] that is and while I was up on
stage I also noticed that like it it
opened and it closed like somebody was
actually up there watching
it's Monday and I'm here with better
help if life came with a user manual
things would be easy for everybody but
it doesn't so when it's not working for
you it's normal to feel stuck I was
stuck for a long time navigating the
career change a new relationship or
becoming a parent can make you feel a
little uncertain there is to train to
help you learn productive coping skills
which makes therapy the closest thing
you'll get to a user manual listen I've
been with better help now I was with him
for over a year Dana helped me to get
coping skills she helped me how to break
down my life slow it down a little bit
to get things going better better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and chat therapy sessions you can
choose to not see anyone or to see up
somebody on camera at the world's
largest therapy service better help us
match three million people with
professional license and better
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with the
therapist if things aren't clip clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more I'm going to get you an opportunity
to save 10 off your first month at
betterhealth.com
Diaz Diaz that's betterhelp.com Diaz
better help if you're feeling stuck the
holidays are coming they could help
betterhelp.com
and now back to the Joint
so I [__] get off the stage I go to
the front bar I get my little water and
my Coke
and the whole guy comes up to me his
name was Richard Cooper I'll never
forget this guy
and he came over to me goes hey man I
watched your set I really enjoyed it
uh how long you've been doing comedy and
I go I don't know [__] uh
seven eight years he goes all right you
know uh uh do your paperwork and call in
for spots I was like
what
and they go to do your paperwork and
call them for spots starting tomorrow
I'm like what the [__] are you talking
about he's like I made you a regular
and I go not for nothing Mr Cooper I
don't even know who you are and he goes
I'm the talent coordinator
and uh blah blah blah blah blah you know
my hand I was I stayed there and all he
goes you're gonna start getting paid now
fifteen dollars a set or whatever
and uh he goes have you met bud
and I go butt who and he goes Bud
Friedman I go well
he goes come on let me let's say hello
congratulate you for becoming like a
regular then I was like what and he took
me in the back and there's Bud Friedman
said with the Barnacle Hi how are you
you know and I'm like like guys I'm
[__] my pants I can't lie to you
but he asked me where are you from are
you Italian I go no I'm Cuban oh I went
to Cuba once and he started talking to
me about my body goes yeah you'll be a
great addition to the family right after
I left he forgot my name was as a matter
of fact I saw him a year later in Miami
I'll never forget this I'm at The Improv
in Miami and Coconut Grove and Buddy
Friedman is there with the owner of the
of the Miami Improv and he looks up and
he sees him and he goes hey look who it
is and you [__] know I can read
lips I saw him say the bud to the owner
of Miami goes what's this guy's name
again and you know I'm not going to yell
at the guy or whatever but at least he
spoke to me and he goes I see you doing
sets you're down here Bob Friedman was a
sweetheart of a guy I had like 20 other
[__] conversations but never as
hmm never as
deep as with Mitzi but we had a nice
relationship I'm very proud I wasn't one
of his favorites you know like I didn't
know him that well but when I'd see bud
I didn't he didn't he talked to me you
know his wife he say hello asked me what
what I was going through what was going
on in my career not that he gave a [__]
but at least he spoke to you you know
and uh guys he did great he did great
for the world of Comedy brought it to a
[__] Forefront you know
those were the pioneers and you got to
give them their [__] props uh if I
don't talk about the Improv as much just
because during the week I was more of a
comedy store guy not because it was a
bad Club I had great [__]
relationships with the Melrose improv
and they took great [__] care of me I
did every year they had me there for the
college football thing every year when
the whoever plays the in Pasadena for
the Rose Bowl they have one night for
one team and one for the other team
every [__] year they called me and
put an envelope in my pocket I don't
know how many you know so if I don't
talk about the Improv it's because and
another grateful thing they improv did
for me the Improv listen The Comedy
Store gave me the fundamentals
you know when you go to Jiu-Jitsu class
yeah when I was I go to Hollis but there
was a girl that was going there and she
told me one time that she went to
another school and I go why do you do
that and she goes because
I want to get the perspective of two or
three different teachers and I didn't
really understand that because I go you
got Hollis and then you got like for the
daytime guys you got [__] my man but
Auto and for the nighttime guys you got
Ray and Lucas and Hollis that's four
[__] different teachers and that's
four different flavors
so that's how I felt about it but she
goes now I like going out of here so
I'll go there twice a week and I'll come
here twice a week whatever works for you
but
I don't give enough thanks to the Improv
I was always involved with the improvs
and let me tell you a [__] great
story about The Improv and I still talk
to this guy
I don't know
it had to be
maybe 2008
I was pretty down in the dumps
um
you know I uh I was finding my way you
know I had just
quit doing drugs cocaine and I was
really finding my way as a comic
and out of nowhere out of nowhere one
night I got a call from a guy named Dan
I used to call him Dan Brandt [__]
great guy great guy another good thing
about the improvs is I could thank
so many of their own like uh general
managers Kelly [__] the Chicken
Melrose I can't I can't draw a blank now
she's I mean I've been friends with her
for 20 years Aaron montempo I've been
friends with for 20 years just they had
really great people I really did care
about comedy and it blew up into it blew
up into a corporation guys so things get
lost in translation
but there was a guy Dan
and uh Dan ran the bray improv for years
Danny was there
I had some history at the bray improv
you know
I got fired one day after doing a
weekend with Pablo they thought we were
doing drugs I wasn't doing drugs
in fact my wife was with me in fact
years later they called me and
apologized because they said sorry you
weren't partying with those guys
but we had a great time at the brand
improv one night some [__] early on
some girl came out and took a top off at
the bray improv and we got in trouble
doesn't [__] you know so I had like a
rocky relationship Oxnard was way out
not Oxnard yeah Oxnard was way out there
uh Ontario was way out there Ontario had
a [__] up situation one night I went
to do Ontario when I was coked up they
gave me a great opportunity to improv I
was like listen we're going to start
headlining you
I'm like okay and they go your first job
is Ontario you're gonna headline on
Wednesday and Thursday you gotta do
radio on
Wednesday morning and Thursday morning I
said fine this is my deep deep junky
days Ontario's about an hour 10 an hour
15 from where I was living in Hollywood
and uh
I drive all the way to Ontario fighting
the urge to do Coke
like I'm not doing coke tonight I'm not
doing coke tonight I'm not doing coke
tonight I'm gonna do these two shows it
it's my first opportunity to headline
the improvs they're going to give me a
ton of work after this the guy likes me
he thinks that there's something to work
with from The Longest Yard
I get to Ontario but
10 o'clock at night
I wrote my number I take a walk around
the neighborhood you know typical [__]
and I uh
about 11 30 12 o'clock I can't do it
guys I can be honest with you guys
I can't do it I can't get this monkey
off my back so I called the coke dealer
in Hollywood
and I drove all the way to Hollywood now
15.
and all the way back to Ontario on hour
I didn't start snorting coke till 2 30
in the morning
and I bought like an eight ball when
that phone rang at seven in the morning
for me to do radio I just picked it up
and kept hanging it up
I never showed for radio
showed up that night there was maybe
like 12 people they were [__] pissed
Thursday night I had like [__] 18
people I got the radio Thursday but the
damage was done already I got the call
when they paid me they're like listen
you [__] up and that's it you're done
with the Improv for a while
go away and come back when you're ready
when you're ready to be a [__] comic
this had to beat like 2007 yeah early
2007.
about 2009 I'm off the coke I thought I
was done with the improvs yeah I was
getting some spots at Melrose but
they were not happy with me and one day
Dan called me from the [__] brand
prop out of the blue like
like the week after [__] New Year's
and he's like hey man
thinking of adding some [__] shows
and I want you
to do Joey Diaz and friends are ready to
show Once a [__] month
we're going to start you with 400 a week
on a show for a budget so that means you
got to pay
three other guys and yourself out of 400
bucks so it's a hundred dollars a
[__] show
they gonna do that for 90 days until you
get going and then after 90 days
you're gonna go door deals so if you
sell 10 tickets you're gonna get ten
dollars you know it was rough guys they
go do you want to do it I was so [__]
just
like I was getting a second chance
so I said abso [__] lutely
and Dan and I worked this together as a
team you know he was like I'm gonna help
you I'm going to give you the mailing
list I'm gonna blast them the first
three four months for you
it's got like 40 000 names you know you
should get
first week I don't know
I probably got 18 people the first time
I did it second month we got like 25.
the third month I probably got 30 and
then the fourth month the month that
we're on a door deal I started all over
again like from eight once he took the
mailing list away so it really taught me
how to
like I did not like social media before
then at all when Dane Cook was being a
star I was like good for Dane good luck
to him if you think I'm Gonna Leave The
Comedy Store well at that time I wasn't
in the store I go if you think I'm gonna
go home after a comedy show and [__]
tweet and Facebook people in Myspace
that's not gonna [__] happen but now
that I had this job and Brea I had to
learn how to [__] Facebook and tweet
quickly
and I I asked Dan I go I don't know how
to get people in he goes well you have
to have fun in common he goes You Can
Have Jesus here but if you don't
program it the right way if you don't
mark it the right way then I'm never
going to come this is how you figure
this out take your humps and your lumps
now and guys
I think a year later we were selling up
selling out 400 seats once a [__] a
month we were like the number three show
that Breya had we weren't from having
nobody I would [__] put on the mate
on the stuff like you know uh
Tuesday night Lindsay Lohan will be here
tonight with a bag of blow I would just
run rampant on [__] uh Facebook and
Twitter somebody's gonna be down here
sucking dick nobody ever asked about
Lindsay Lohan
like people come and get them like I
would take a [__] edible cake and put
it in the back table
these things became wild they were
[__] known people were having a great
time I ended up taping my first CD there
without even knowing two Comics canceled
and I remember telling Lee I don't know
what I'm gonna do and he's like well
let's tape it and that was [__] it's
either you or the priest unbelievable
story you know
a packed [__] house packed
we would have Edibles down there and
weed and [__] 20 people would come
down to hang out it was a it was a great
experience but my point was I'll never
forget being at the Melrose improv and
Bud Freeman was there and he was like
amen
can I talk to you for a second I'm like
yeah what's up he's like congratulations
and I felt so [__] good
congratulations for what
for a movie he goes no
for what you've done down in Brea you
built it up from scratch
I still remember [__] uh I learned
the valuable lesson that week down there
were these people that always came to
the show but I gave them free tickets
and one night out of the kindness it was
hard Rogan called me I would never call
Joe or ask him to do the room no he
called me and he's like I gotta shoot
something down there
do you mind if I stop by or do you mind
if I put your name down he goes nah just
put my name down I'll never forget that
those people called and said hey man we
need free tickets and I go I can't give
them to you because they're a rogue in
the show
and they paid anyway
and that's when I learned that
people will pay the fifteen dollars for
a [__] decade you don't have to give
them free tickets constantly they should
pay you built the value that's when I
learned the value of [__] stand up
and I remember seeing them that night
and like oh you got tickets and they're
like yeah but we didn't really want to
pay well it's Joe Rogan you got a
[__] pay them do it and this goes
back
2 000 [__] 10 you know
so when Bud said that to me at the
Melrose improv that's probably the last
time I saw bud I might have seen Bud one
time after that I think I saw one of the
I think a mountains I don't know I don't
know but I saw a bud
because Maryland's wake would have been
three years early I saw but uh
and he congratulated me and
it was just a great [__] feeling so
yeah I learned comedy from the store the
basics but I learned how to sell a
ticket
from Dan at that Bray improv so I'm
really grateful and I'm really sorry I
don't tell a lot of these improv stories
you know the
the hot commodity for me was a comedy
store so I didn't want people to sound
like you know the Improv was my second
home the Laugh Factory started giving me
spots
after the podcast before the podcast I
didn't belong that but after the podcast
people started selling tickets then
they started giving me uh and that's a
great Club too I never had none against
Jamie or anything like that anyway I
want to wrap it up with this real quick
I'm going to talk to you guys about
something
guys I got locked up if you guys think
that
when I got out of prison listen before I
went to prison I didn't think I could do
anything in my life
and when I got out of prison I
definitely didn't think I could do
anything in my life but like you know
you can't be a [__] bum you can't
collect disability you got to do
something you got to earn your keep you
got to Justify Your Existence so
somewhere along the line
I came up with the idea
of trying stand-up comedy and becoming
stand-up stand-up comic it worked for my
lifestyle I was a [__] uh
I was a renegade I had no
I had I had a little bit of discipline
but really no discipline but I was a
renegade
I was living I had no family no wife you
know I had a kid that at this point
whatever but that's the way I ran my
life I was always a renegade I felt
comedy
fit my needs at the time I liked that I
liked my days I didn't want to work
nights and somewhere along the line I
got the [__] balls after a year to go
up there on stage now
when I got on that stage when I got off
that stage yes I saw
I saw a little
I saw a little hope in my life but I
didn't see a Hope by telling you people
that as soon as I got on stage I went
home and I was like I'm gonna be a
[__] TV star I'm going to be a movie
star it wasn't that type of Hope
I saw hope for me to stop living the
life I was living to maybe get a little
bit more control pay some bills get an
apartment sometime in your life I wasn't
going to get remarried I wasn't going to
do any of this [__] I was going to live
like Charles Bronson
the last thing on my [__] mind during
those days
from year one to year five of Comedy to
year 10 of Comedy I did not see any hope
for success
honesty I mean I could be honest what do
you mean by that Joey I didn't see
any glimmer of hope for me to ever make
it as a stand-up comic I was
very insecure about who I was
I was very insecure about the lifestyle
I had lived as a young man I was a
criminal I got locked up I'm a junkie
and now I want to give my [__] uh I
want to give comedy a try what makes you
think you can make it in the comedy game
and that's exactly how I thought I
thought I could just get on Triple runs
for the rest of my life there was no
movie career there was no commercial
career I just knew that I had a career
as a road comic
that's it there was not going to be an
HBO special there was not going to be a
letterman appearance none of that [__]
was going to be possible in my life and
yeah I was a little negative but I was
just trying to be honest with myself as
honest as I could [__] be but I'm a
piece of [__] I come from nothing I come
from North Bergen New Jersey named the
last buck and comedian on Hollywood star
musician to come out of North Bergen
yeah what were my [__] chances so
but somehow I started I ended up in LA
and I I ended up at the comedy store and
still there was no hope of me being Dave
Chappelle or Kevin Hart and doing movies
with The Rock I just wanted to be a
funny [__] stand-up comic and earn my
steak at the table earn my steak at the
table that's all I want well things
happened and we ended up here
if you guys
if you [__] think
that for one minute
I thought I was going to do anything
good with comedy
believe that but
if you [__] think that I
thought I would ever ever get off drugs
that was never gonna happen
I made a conscious decision
in maybe 95 that I'm not going to go
back and forth with this this is the way
to lose your [__] mind
I'm gonna get clean after this I'm never
gonna snort coke I'm never gonna drink
again listen
just telling yourself that lie back and
forth that's enough to drive you [__]
crazy and I was okay with it I said you
know what listen what's all this
[__] what's all this beating myself
up I'm not gonna go to a [__] meeting
I'm not gonna get clean it's not gonna
happen I'm not gonna put this
restriction on myself to say to myself
okay I'm not going to do Coke this week
on the road by night sexy you're
disappointed you meet a blonde you know
she wants to do Coke there you are I
mean come on come on it was not gonna
end for me so I I never saw it coming
never in my wildest lives
but I see cocaine coming to an end I
didn't see me dying from it
not yet because I was a [__] junkie
and I'm an addict but I didn't see
myself
ever stopping ever wanting to stop at
once I met Terry there were little
[__] things that I was like
I gotta take care of this before it hits
home before she knows before I get a DUI
before I got arrested at an airport you
know what I'm saying I didn't want her
to be a total shock to her
so I did sign up for some like Hollywood
run and rehabs you know that you and I
would give them a fake name and then
three days later somebody would go hey I
saw you at the comedy store two weeks
ago they didn't know Joey Diaz didn't
know anything like that they would just
say hey look and then after I did The
Longest Yard forget about going through
a [__] rehab and those meetings and
[__]
but I did go to a few meetings just to
see what they were about but I went to
Hollywood and I was like oh
you know people getting AA tattoos and I
think I think the first meeting I went
to in Hollywood some lady got up and
she's like I came to a meeting last week
and somebody groped me
and I looked at her nobody would ever
even dream or groping up but that was
her beef for the day that somebody
groped her so I didn't go back to a a
meeting in La I started I went to a
meeting when I Shot the movie Boiler
Room
I figured I'd go up and uh it's so
[__] weird I figured up and go up and
see where they did this the movie Boiler
Room is about a AAA meeting
that got crashed by a bank robbery two
bank robbers were hiding from the cops
and they went into this AAA meeting and
they took it hostage and this really
happened and this particular meeting and
wherever it's held in Burbank or I
forget what where it was held guys
uh Studio City or one of those
this particular meeting is the big
Monday night meeting
for the valley that's where all the
stars go a lot of [__] people go up
there so I when I got this movie when I
did the table read and they said that uh
the the movie was going to get shot in
like 90 days
I decided on my own to just go up to up
down a meeting one day I recognized some
of the people there with some comedians
there that I don't need to discuss their
names because obviously they're friends
that John's and they take it seriously
but it was a great feeling you know I
went I watched but still knew sobriety
was not for me and you know maybe a year
and a half later I got the call to do
[__] uh whatever movie whatever it
was called and
they told me that the movie because I
did the table read for this movie and I
can't remember what what the [__] was
Boilermaker was it Boilermaker yeah
because Boiler Room is the one about
[__] gianato rabisi calling people
and going to jail and [__] Boilermakers
about so I probably got the read I
probably read the table read from the
guy the reason why I want to do
Boilermaker was because it had the guy
from the fighter in it way before the
fighter he was just working on uh on the
he was a fireman in the [__] show
with Dennis Leary but I loved him he was
a good guy I saw him and Lethal Weapon
too he's been around forever so when I
saw him at the table read I was like
okay I want to do this movie the movie
was paying here before it got cast but
once they cast it and they called me a
year later the movie paid a hundred
dollars a [__] day and I was like
[__] do I even want to do this movie
[Music]
so I went over to they said you don't
even have to read just go meet with the
new producers I went up to
I guess I had to meet with them in the
valley one day somewhere and I walked in
it was a great read and they [__]
went over the script with me and they
expected they said listen I don't know
if you know this
is a low budget production so we're
shooting this
was shooting three
weeks of 12-hour days
we're going to start shooting on
November
8th and whatever it ends around
Thanksgiving
and I was like okay I'm in there like we
got to talk to you about one more thing
and I'm like what
and like we'd like to speak to you about
your substance abuse [__] problem and
I'm like what
and they're like we really want to talk
to you about your substance abuse
problem
I'm like okay hit me and they go because
the movie is
getting shot in
three weeks and everybody's in the shoot
you cannot miss a day in fact you can't
even miss an hour
we're gonna shoot this you know long
days
fast but if you miss a day you [__] the
whole production up
so we don't want you to give us an
answer on this film right now
call us tomorrow let us think about it
let us know what you want to do
and this conversational stay here I was
a little agitated at that conversation
when I walked out they paid me a hundred
dollars a day and they're trying to go
into my [__] private life
there was just like a little [__]
thing stopping me
from going in there this will happen
like
all this happened at the same [__]
time
I'll never forget getting in my car and
going to [__] these [__] I'm not
doing this [__] movie talk to me like
that that's the mind of a junkie talking
by the time I got home I'm like you know
what
they got a point they're making a huge
investment
and uh
I get it so I got a decision
whether I could stay off cocaine
because it was 21 days whether I could
stay off cocaine or whether I can't do
this movie
all of a sudden some things happen the
cat me boom bam
I took the movie
and I took the movie because
was long days and it wouldn't give my
mind a chance to think about cocaine
when I did I was on the set
and I got to be honest with you
I got on that set I completed my 21 days
I did the [__] movie I did the best
job I could
there was one beef on the movie one day
I went there on a Sunday and there was
no food so I told him I was going home
because you have to have food we pay
Union prices but besides that everything
worked out in the movie was great
but at the end of that movie I realized
that I was sober for 22 [__] days
and I was like holy [__]
it's time to go get a [__] huge eight
ball like an a it's time to go get an
eight ball with all the [__]
trimmings
and I gotta tell you something I said
why
I've already done this for 22 days why
would I want to [__]
go back and do Coke
and that was 15 years ago
tomorrow guys
15 years ago I clocked it at the 15th we
finished the movie like
the day before Thanksgiving because that
was our first day off was Thanksgiving
we went straight for three [__] weeks
so
whatever that movie started I didn't
look at the calendar and uh I was 15
years ago
this week guys when I decided to make
that decision so if you [__]
think
I never had a chance at [__] doing
anything in the stand-up comedy
community when the film Community where
the [__] do you guys think I was at with
drugs and doing cocaine when I was doing
coke five six nights a week
the reason I tell you this story is
because the holidays are coming a lot of
years of living with this [__] in your
life not that I'm here to judge it I
don't give a Frenchman's [__] I feel
myself a quitter for quit you know what
I'm saying you guys keep the party alive
but I gotta be honest right there if I
tell you all the good things that came
my way
in these 15 years compared to my first
you know 45 [__] years
because I was 44 when I quit cocaine
because John Gotti took over the
gambinos at 45 and I had to take control
of my [__] life so I wanted to be
clean by the time I was 45. all this
[__] that I had done it came to an end
15 years ago this week and guys I never
ever ever thought ever that I would get
clean if I never ever thought I was
going to do anything in comedy what were
my chances of getting [__] off
cocaine
but through the [__] I don't know I
don't know how so today this podcast is
about
2023's coming you want to be Tip Top
[__] Magoo because think about
it I didn't do [__] with my life except
go to prison do drugs for 44 [__]
years I could tell you five good things
I did in those 44 years but I could tell
you 20 good things I did the last 15
years I'm not telling you that sobriety
is going to [__] open up of
opportunity of whatever for you you're
going to be hanging out on the beach
with Brad Pitt I know it's saying that
I'm just saying that if you got a chance
of doing something if you clean up from
whatever the [__] you're doing
you're giving you're giving your life a
bit way better chance like I said I did
more than 15 [__] years
than I did in 44 [__] years
that's the joint on Monday the 14th of
the [__] month uh that's it and
that's that I love you [__] with
all my heart stay black and I'll see you
Thursday morning Tip Top Magoo and now
for a word for [__] sponsors
[Music]
[__] Savages thank you for letting me
tell you my story on a beautiful Monday
on morning but before you leave this
episode is sponsored by better help
listen life doesn't come with a user
manual but we can make it a little
easier for everybody but it doesn't so
when it's not working for you it's
normal to feel stuck navigating the
career change a new relationship
becoming a parent they're all big steps
in there a lot of uncertainty therapists
are trained to help you learn productive
coping skills which makes therapy the
closest thing you'll get to a user
manual so do me a favor therapy is
important nowadays especially what was
going on the last couple years maybe you
feel a little trapped better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions you could
choose not to see anyone on camera or
see somebody as the world's largest
therapy service better help this match
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists of
available 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be easier no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
Diaz again that's betterhelp.com Diaz
the joint is also brought to you by on
it listen I love on it but like I said
earlier 2023 is coming and you want to
be ready for some Alpha Brain some
shroom Tech some new mood you want to be
getting ready to work out and honor is
there to help you go to 100.com read
learn see what they got now they can
help you from the protein powder to the
kettlebells to the club listen I can't
help you with the kettlebells or the
club bats but I could get you 10 off on
all their products go to honda.com
pressing code Joey joint or church and
get 10 off your first order I want to
thank
betterhelp.com and I want to thank
audit.com but most importantly I want to
thank you savages for always having my
back have a great day and I'll talk to
you guys Thursday morning
foreign